in an industry where design dictates
Destinies do you have the tools and the
apps at your disposal to rise to the top
I do and I want to share them with you
don't be fooled though this collection
of apps isn't for those looking just to
get a little bit better this is for
those looking to project their career
decades ahead they're not all free
they're not for everybody but they have
worked for me if you're new here my name
is David Tomic I'm an award-winning
architect here in Western Australia and
today I'm preparing you for dig ual
greatness I'm handing you the apps I
personally use on a daily basis
transform ideas into reality after
sitting through the endless maze known
as the App Store I've emerged with my
top five each a Titan in their own right
po to transform your Concepts and turn
your designs into awardwinning work
we'll break it down into five categories
each with only one winner the categories
being design render management present
and innovate make sure you watch the end
of this video because there's one tool
that slipped under the radar for a long
time the dark horse that could be the
game changer you've been waiting for not
only will it Propel your career there's
also a good chance it will increase your
fee proposals too first up is Mor folio
trace the sketch artists digital canvas
imagine tracing paper wet high-tech and
you've got trace this app is a game
changer for architects who value the art
of freehand in a digital world yes you
will need an iPad and you will need a
pencil to make this work though it's
perfect for those initial brainstorming
sessions where creativity flows without
bounce and with its arsenal of tools you
can overlay sketch iterate faster than
ever before whether you're refining a
design concept or presenting options to
a client morpholio Trace brings your
ideas to life some of my favorite
features in Trace are the scale ruler
the Recently Added liar room scanner
which can quickly convert any space into
a floor plan and of course the layers to
all I'm not much of an artist but I hate
wasting paper this is why it is the
perfect replacement for any
Sketchbook now you've seen the title
screen for this next chapter and you're
probably thinking what the actual FIV
isn't a rendering app David no it is so
much more zooming in on Fiverr it's not
just a Marketplace it's your gateway to
a world brimming with specialized Talent
as Architects we're Visionaries but even
Visionaries need a t let's picture this
a platform where a few clicks connects
you to experts who bring your plans to
life with stunning renders think of
hyper realistic visuals that could have
you mistaken for walking through your
designs in real life and here's the real
kick up five is about smart scaling for
solo practitioners and small firms it's
the ace up your sleeve it allows you to
punch above your weight taking on more
ambitious projects by extending your
team on demand no continuous overheads
no wages when work is running low only
upside with fiver you're not just
Outsourcing tasks you're curating a team
of season Pros to help you elevate your
work you're managing a collaborative
process from the comfort of your own
Studio which to be fair considering it's
almost 2024 if you haven't been doing
this for years now you've already missed
the boat now let's move on and unpack
notion the organizational Powerhouse
that redefines how Architects manage
their masterpieces from inception to
reveal it's not about tracking it's
about orchestrating your Project's
Symphony architecture is no longer a
solar act there are multiple Consultants
involved to make a dream come true all
of whom need to be coordinated with
notion you're the Maestro of a dashboard
that harmonizes your project timelines
Consultants databases and your ever
growing list of to-do items but it
doesn't stop there imagine a world where
you can drag and drop tasks set
reminders that sync to your calendar and
share live updates with your team notion
doesn't just keep track of your projects
it propels you forward say goodbye to
the chaos of email chains because with
notion every communication every
document every critical piece of your
project is right there where you need it
to be imagine this you're in a meeting
and the client asks for an update on the
latest revision no need to scramble
through emails or call the office one
click in notion and you're presenting
the latest progress complete with
comments images and timelines whether
you're tracking the big picture or the
minute by- minute details Notions
flexible platform means it's tailored to
the way you work it's about taking the
reign of your Project's narrative
ensuring nothing slips through the
cracks ever again Embrace notion and
you're not just managing projects you're
mastering the art of organization it's
this kind of proficiency that can leads
to Promotions to clients that trust you
and to a portfolio that speaks volumes
now remember apps like notion don't
actually do anything for you you need to
set up the templates you need to manage
them and you need to put the effort in
success doesn't just happen but you are
on the right track at least
transitioning from the drawing board to
the boardroom let's talk about
programmer this isn't your ordinary
presentation tool it's where
architectural documents don't just live
they speak programmer elevates the art
of presentation here every spec sheet
every render every intricate detail of
your building plans is not just
displayed it's showcased in an
interactive portfolio imagine unveiling
your Project's details with cinematic
flare as you scroll through documents
your clients are engaged their
experience seamless as they guide
through layers of your Design's DNA from
the granula to the Grand programmer
ensures that your work is not just seen
but it's truly experienced the way it's
meant to be it's storytelling through
documentation where every line every
curve holds a narrative where whether
it's a critical stakeholder meeting or
an impromptu team huddle programmer
serves you as the digital dosier
programmer isn't just about organizing
your projects it's about bringing them
to life in the eyes of those who matter
it's where your designs do the talking
and where your architecture abilities
are indisputable next in our digital
toolkit is PR me AI sadly this isn't an
app but it's a website at least for now
but it's still a visionary's best Ally
on the web it's where your architectural
cont Concepts leap off the sketch page
and into virtual life promy AI isn't
about creating it's about elevating it
takes your rough sketches and transforms
them into polished professional
presentations no more static floor plans
you'll be offering clients and
stakeholders an interactive Journey
Through Your Vision whether it's a
renovation project begging for a modern
twist or a groundup creation promy ai's
AI driven engine brings finesse to your
presentation that static images could
just never deliver and in this era where
presentation is as crucial as creation
pry AI stands out by turning your design
proposals into immersive experiences for
Architects looking to Captivate and
convince pry AI is your go-to platform
we all know that AI isn't ready to take
over our jobs as Architects but it is an
excellent tool when you're experiencing
brain block promy AI provides a quick
and simple super userfriendly experience
anyone can benefit from let's compare
and analyze these tools we've discussed
so we can outline their unique benefits
and potential impact on your
architectural workflow remember the Dark
Horse is yet to show its head starting
with Mor folio Trace it's best for early
design phases freehand sketching its
unique benefits allow Architects to draw
and iterate quickly as if using
traditional tracing paper but with
digital
convenience fi is best for expanding
your team virtually Outsourcing tasks
like rendering it provides access to
loable toal and pool enhancing project
capabilities without the need for
full-time staff notion is best for
project management information and
organization its unique benefits
centralized project components in one
easily navigatable interface
streamlining workflows and
communication programmer is best
presenting documents in a visually
engaging manner its unique benefit
transforms mundane presentation tasks
into interactive storytelling
experiences and of course primy AI is
best for generating creative designs
with AI particularly for designers and
professionals needing quick visual
proposals it offers an extensive library
of controllable AI generated content
including models assisting with a wide
range of design scenarios from
e-commerce to architectural planning
each tool offers a distinct advantage
and it can be leveraged different stages
of the architectural process from
conceptual sketches to detailed project
management and even presentation this
choice of tool would depend on the
specific needs of the task at hand
whether it's creative ideation detailed
project planning resource management or
even client presentations let's sign in
on a couple Pro tips that can truly make
a difference in your architectural
practice firstly when it comes to fiver
always play the long game have not one
but two Freelancers you can trust on
rotation why it's your safety net should
one be unavailable you've got to back up
without skipping a beat and remember
train them well your Freelancers should
understand your style your expectations
so even in a pinch they can deliver
quality that aligns with your standards
moving on to promy AI use it as a
brainstorming partner let the AI suggest
elevation ideas then take those and
refine them with your expertise the key
here is never let the AI dictate your
designs it's a tool not the architect
you are the architect these tips aren't
just about using tools they're about
leveraging them to build your reputation
to ensure resilience in your practice
and to keep your creativity at the
Forefront that's how you build an
architectural Legacy and now for that
Dark Horse I've been alluding to this
whole video the unsung hero of every
successful project drum roll
please the DIY architectural brief is
not just about starting it's about
starting right every dream build from
the coy Corner House to the next
architectural Marvel hinges on a clear
concise brief over my career I've
witnessed the transformative power of a
world crafted brief it's the compass
that guides your project the blueprint
of your client's Vision without it
you're sailing blind in a sea of
escalating cost and directionless design
that's why I've crafted this tool it's
your first step towards architectural
Excellence this DIY brief is your
collaborative campas a starting point
that ensures you and your clients are
aligned from the get-go setting a solid
foundation for everything that follows
don't leave your architectural Legacy to
chance swing by my website link down
below and secure your DIY architectural
brief today it is more than a template
it is the Cornerstone of your future
success it can be used with any
architect around the world for any
residential project it doesn't matter if
you're the client or the architect this
template is perfect for your project the
costs will quickly pay for itself by
avoiding unnecessary variation fees due
to directionless design anyway that's
all from me team I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did subscribe for more
weekly content